[Musik]
er ist einer von denen die am großen
fraumünster postraub in zürich beteiligt
waren
heute 15 jahre später wird er wegen
einer neuen straftat verurteilt
als der zustrom domenico es war der
fahrer der bande wie alle anderen wurde
er verurteilt und hat seine strafe
längst abgesessen
heute schreibt er am zweiten buch über
den legendären frau münster post
thorandt frau war 19 als er beim
überfall auf die frau münster post
kriminellen wurde
er sucht 15 jahre nach dem raub immer
noch nach seinen beuteanteil was ist
damals geschehen und was ist heute 15
jahre später aus dem post räubern
geworden
[Musik]
erster september 1997 morgens kurz nach
halb elf in so einem auto sitzen fünf
junge männer
sie werden kriminalgeschichte schreiben
getarnt als post- mitarbeiter fahren sie
in die frau münster post mitten in
zürich
[Musik]
ein postangestellter gab ihnen den tipp
dass im posthof immer zum monatsende
mehrere geld kisten für den transport
zur nationalbank bereitstehen unbewacht
sie bedrohen die angestellten mit
spielzeugpistolen und einer ungeladenen
kalaschnikow ungestört laden die jungen
männer geld kiste für geld kisten in ihr
auto
das auto ist zu klein sie können nicht
alle kisten einladen
nach nur vier minuten passieren sie die
schleuse und fahren ungehindert aus dem
posthof
es gibt keine verletzten die beute 53
millionen schweizer franken
die meldung des dreisten raubes geht um
die welt
es gibt mehrere gründe warum der
raubkatze besonders sticht und immer
noch aktuell ist ein die schon mal die
hoch liegt so nah das ist europaweit die
grösste deliktsumme wo in meiner post ag
erzielt worden ist dann der zweite grund
ist sicher will bis zum pazifik mit der
tat natürlich nicht sauber bis wird
machen aber sympathisiert will dass es
gerade dann nicht um mord und totschlag
sondern es geht um schlaue täter wo ihn
einmal in ihrem labor der große gewinn
erzielt und auch an jemand verletzt
hatte
wenn mitarbeitern ist detail york dann
wandelt sich das bild
das sind sie die unrühmlichen helden
dieser geschichte mario p der
postangestellte und tippgebern maurizio
v in seinem lokal trafen sich die täter
für die planung der tat
elias a der chef der bande welcher den
ersten fehler machte
hasani 1 kisten träger
[Musik]
domenico es der fahrer dieter m auch 1
kisten träger und der jüngste voran v
[Musik]
mit viel glück entkommt die bande die
tat zwar minuziös geplant aber ab hier
haben sie keinen plan mehr
sie teilen die beute erstmal auf dass
das so schwer ist dass in allen fällen
infrage kommen mein gott wir haben post
überfahren mit einem instrument das
große münz sind 53 millionen schweizer
franken in noten die täter verpacken ihr
geld in plastiksäcke und fahren mit dem
drang nach hause
[Musik]
es war das geld gesehen dass die gang
dann das ganze wert in der hand gehabt
habe ich es probiert man zu zählen
damit das ganze geld auf den beitrag
dann erzähle ich bin ich hier ungefähr
bis 7000 gekommen 7000 fans gesagt ja
das ist genug ich zeige ja nichts mehr
das ist zu lange zum zählen da gedacht
dass das ich habe so lange braucht man
außer zum ausgeben brauche sicher noch
fünf sechs jahre zum das ganze geld
ausgeben oder nichts machen
die zinsen zum 6 er täuscht sich
gewaltig schnell verschwinden die beute
anteile in den unterschiedlichsten
verstecken bei verschiedensten
helfershelfern und alle täter fliehen
ins ausland
der erste fehler passierte aber bereits
im posthof aus dem fluchtauto vielen
fotos diese brauchten die täter um sich
am tatort orientieren zu können
auf den fotos waren fingerabdrücke des
vorbestraften chefs der wandel
die photokina weise ich selbst und ich
habe vor regierung verlassen habe ich
ihm gesagt gib mir ich werde das
wegschmeißen
und er sagt ich brauche es muss wieder
etwas erklären an die jungs ich brauche
noch ok aber nicht vergessen ich das
eigentlich wenig ihn zugegangen
seit erwerbung ist ganz vielfältige
größten zieht und msg hat minister otto
schily standen auch ein sehr großer
personellen umfang sie unserem bezirk
vorgaben zur logistik komme überhaupt
nicht von der technik über 100
mitarbeitende der polizei sind im
einsatz
das hat die schweiz noch nie erlebt das
mediale großereignis bringt auch viele
hinweise aus der bevölkerung
die erste spur führt in ein hotel nach
mailand dort werden 40.000 franken aus
dem raub beschlagnahmt und der
bandenchef elias a sowie seine freundin
und ein hehler paar verhaftet
mario der tippgeber arbeitet weiter auf
der fraumünster post als ob nichts
gewesen wäre
er hält es fast nicht aus die
verschiedene postangestellte werden
verhört
auch er mehrmals nicht sagen aber
plötzlich eine seite von mir wird auch
die wahrheit sagen weil geschlossen also
[Musik]
explodiert also jemand erzählen
nach sieben tage mutig verhaftet
diese situation richtig gesagt ich habe
mich sehr gut tut nasini
untersuchungsrichter haft tiefen armen
erinnere honig im gefundene präsentiert
haben ich hab damals kühl klinischer
welt seiner brauche er hat mir dennoch
erwartet und mit ihm versprochen dass
die photonen vernichtet werden und woher
die folgt ein bbc hat das bei ihm
besuchs gelöst nämlich das gestein ist
bei zur an frau und die tm geht es nicht
viel länger
sie schaffen es zwar bis nach spanien
aber sie kaufen eine protzige villen mit
dem vielen geld im spielcasino und
machen sich so schnell verdächtig die tm
wird zuerst verhaftet zoran v will sich
nach afrika absetzen
was dann passierte zeigt er uns als wir
ihn 2002 in spanien aufsuchen wo er nach
absitzen der strafe liegt
näher gekommen da war aus staub und
nicht aber die polizei waren damit
ungefähr 43 und da hab ich schon polizei
gemeint aber ich habe gemacht gemeint
das ist eine routinekontrolle dann bin
ich weiter gefahren und er antreten das
war der taxifahrer dann kommen wir da
ran am punkt buchen wir gestanden hat
also neben polizei gestanden
das verstopft war das sehr gut da
telefonisch sei aber im pass weil
dokumente und dann dann fahre ich aber
war leider nicht so rahn wird verhaftet
landet in spanien im gefängnis er hat
bargeld von 1,3 millionen und teuren
schmuck im gepäck ein kinderspiel für
die fahnder einer bereichert sich dabei
wahrscheinlich selbst das beschlagnahmte
geld wird nämlich nie in der schweiz
ankommen erzählt sichergestellt wissen
haben das ist sicher mal taxi vom 7
sie hat sich schon über nachteile sowie
mehr auskömmlich sind im haushalt wo
rückstand zur ans methode zu flüchten
bzw das beute geld einfach so im koffer
mitzutragen mutet heute 15 jahre später
geradezu altmodisch an die justiz hat
heutzutage mit ganz anderen tätern zu
tun einfach so einen fensterplatz wiese
die spur von dem täter zu finden ihnen
als wiese dass sie das alles so krist
und also wähle hand aus über die moderne
formen vor schädigenden verhaltens
wissen im unternehmen im finanzbereich
oder im bankenbereich da tut man sich
der strafverfolgung unheimlich viel
schwerer
beim fraumünster postrock spürt die
polizei innerhalb von fünf tagen rund 20
millionen der beute auf das meiste in
wohnung über 18 millionen allein in
einem schlafzimmerschrank einer helfers
helferin aber der rest der beute bleibt
bis heute verschwunden
noch jahrelang geht die polizei
unzähligen hinweisen unter anderem auch
von hellsehern nach wie hier
beispielsweise in einem alten bunker am
uetliberg bei zürich
die suche treibt manchmal seltsame
blüten 40 gräber werden geöffnet
erfolglos keine spur vom restlichen geld
für die post ein riesiger verlust von
rund 20 millionen franken sind bis jetzt
nicht auftaucht und tv aktuell rutscht
das ist also etwas unternimmt nutzung
hat escada nach rust respektiv behörde
1000 neue der letzten jahre mit einem
der drei möglichkeiten bis zusatz werk
zweiten also rechnet damit dass das geld
verloren irgendwo auftaucht aber so
lässt die post auch verlauten die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen seien inzwischen
so gut dass ein solch dreister raub in
der frau münster post nicht mehr möglich
wäre
bis miami schafft es der letzte täter
erst 15 monate nach der tat wird der
fahrer des fluchtautos domenico es in
einer filmreifen szene verhaftet
er verhielt sich zuerst sehr clever aber
irgendwann telefonierte er doch mit
seiner freundin in der schweiz die falle
schnappt zu geld findet man bei ihm
keines
ich habe mir berichten lassen dass das
generalstabsmäßig abgelaufen ist
an der front mit dabei zwei polizisten
der kriminalpolizei von zürich und
diverse spezialeinheiten der polizei von
miami
und so stehen die haupttäter schließlich
rund zwei jahre nach der tat alle vor
gericht und erhalten strafen zwischen
zwei und sechseinhalb jahren gefängnis
die höchste strafe erhält der
postangestellte mario p der
strafvollzugs fragt man was man mit der
strafe privat auffange
dann aber mehr um
resozialisierungsmaßnahmen sommer wird
die leute dazu bringen dass sie in
zukunft sicherlich auf erhalten dass sie
vielleicht lernt im strafvollzug
also das sind ihre integrative element
im vordergrund in diesem fall ist die
resozialisierung größtenteils misslungen
fünf von sieben haupttätern sind
inzwischen wieder straffällig geworden
einer von ihnen ist mauritius in seiner
bar trafen sich die täter um den raub zu
planen zwei jahre war maurizio im
gefängnis kaum draußen hat er schon
wieder einen prozess am hals wegen
hehlerei eine spätfolge des post raubes
die schweiz wenn eine solche fehler
macht wird mir klar
und vielleicht ist ein richtiges oper
ist jetzt mit richtiger gewohnt das ganz
hinter premiere seinen beuteanteil habe
er nie gesehen behauptet er hartnäckig
trotzdem wird ihm vorgeworfen dass er
nach dem postraub eine tasche mit rund
13 millionen transportiert haben soll
dass er deswegen nochmals vor gericht
muss das versteht ihr irgendwie ganz und
gar nicht er der doch geschworen hatte
jetzt wirklich ein guter mensch zu
werden
wie sie einst galten die nicht sie sind
das weiß ich nicht weil ich nie kalt x6
und migriert hat und wie 200 m2 lied von
mauritius hat glück die sache ist 2007
sowieso verehrt und der wird in zweiter
instanz freigesprochen
zoran v welcher in spanien mit einem
teil der beute verhaftet wurde musste
zur strafe in die
arbeitserziehungsanstalt und ins
gefängnis
danach wurde er ausgewiesen
wir besuchen ihn 2002 in spanien er lebt
dort weil seine frau spanierin ist woran
wurde mit 18 jahren zum ersten mal vater
inzwischen ist er 25 jahre alt und
träumt noch immer vom großen geld also
dezentral traum hat sich erfüllt ohne
gelder platz sicherte
ferner habe ich nicht darüber 19 ich
mache das einfach
jetzt denke ich mir folgen sind dann
denke ich wenn ich etwas war und etwas
passiert dann muss ich wieder im
gefängnis haben sich wieder
dann war sage ich ja ich arbeite lieber
und mache nichts und wenn hierdurch
normalen normalen level zu führen ist
ein bisschen schwierig und auch so viele
viele jahre gefängnis und dann kommst du
da raus und dann jeder betrachtet war
sehr bis spezielles in videos zeichnet
speziell weil du hast ein raub gemacht
und dann die maintaler studieren top
story und die fahrt du hast geht oder
darum geht verschiedene banken gebunkert
oder nicht wem er den rest seines beute
anteils gegeben hat das wird er sicher
nicht vergessen haben
die 26 millionen können sich ja nicht in
luft aufgelöst haben
das findet sogar die überzeugung dass in
mindestens sein beuteanteil zusteht
treibt ihn wie ein unsichtbarer motor
durchs leben
[Musik]
und trotz einreiseverbot taucht er ein
jahr später bereits wieder in zürich auf
[Musik]
also eine noch zu wenig besucher familie
wo man eine frau
und sie nicht das geld suchen gekommen
nein ich habe ja da nichts auch nichts
verloren kein geld und ich suche ja kein
geld da für mich ist es schon lange
vorbei und das interessiert mich nicht
mehr
am nächsten tag wird er verhaftet und
später an die grenze gestellt
vom postraub haben wahrscheinlich viele
helfershelfer profitiert es ist
schwierig ihnen nachzuweisen dass sie
das geld ihrerseits wieder ausgegeben
oder gewaschen haben
[Musik]
wie ist das eigentlich jetzt die hände
gelegt wird zum teil oder hat deshalb
sogar überholen das investiert dann
könnte sich in sicherheit wähnen
wer schmutziges geld annimmt der kasimir
in sicherheit wiegen
ja will jedes mal wenn geld unsere
straftat stammt insbesondere aus man
derartige ob sich die schuldig mache der
hehlerei oder geldwäscherei und das
verfolgen natürlich das heißt wenn
jemand wissentlich geld welches aus dem
postraub stammt braucht oder weitergibt
macht er sich auch heute noch strafbar
mario pi hat aus seiner lektion gelernt
er war der postangestellte und insider
er erhielt die höchste strafe
sechseinhalb jahre wegen guter führung
wird er 2002 nach über vier jahren haft
aus dem gefängnis entlassen besucht hat
ihn im gefängnis außer seiner mutter
niemand dafür haben ihm mitinsassen
angeboten einen mord zu begehen wenn er
mit ihnen die beute teilen würde
das war eine ziemlich neue welt für den
bisher unbescholtenen jungen mann klar
zu viel lerne dich nicht mehr gehört
leute gesicht
tolle frauen
klar das ist ein schock das ist ein
erster schock
nochmal für das gericht hatte
landesverweisung angeordnet
wo sein anteil von 8 millionen
hingekommen ist davon will mario keine
ahnung haben und nimmt den nächsten zug
nach italien
wenn er sagt dass es garten im heck den
könnte das aber sie will mir hand
einerseits einbruch kam rallye geschafft
wo der betrag ist wo man hin wie sand
dass das vermutlich in altheim handkerum
mit aber wieder andere irgendwie so dem
widersprach aber sagen dass er es galt
rechtzeitig lüthi nach italien aber und
mich an der hinweis dass in italien
bekannt wie lüd und braucht worte sind
nach mafia art und einer warten im auto
eine im zusammenhang mit dem geld wolle
er offiziell bestreitet dass er sie
keine tiere weil er sie vielleicht doch
kennt versteckte sich zuerst einmal bei
seinen eltern in süditalien
sie haben jahrelang in der schweiz büros
geputzt und sind während seiner haft
wieder in ihre heimat gezogen ist es nur
taktik den reuigen sohn zu spielen
oder hat er wirklich keine ahnung wo das
geld sein könnte die antwort weiß nur er
selbst
[Musik]
hier fällt mir nichts vorher fällt mir
auch nichts aber ich war zu jung naiv
ein bisschen dumm und klar habe ich
diese fehler gemacht aber nach dieser
situation habe ich gemerkt was ich
wirklich hatte was ich wirklich verliert
habe
jetzt kann ich mich besser genießt
genießen heißt in seinem fall für einen
kleinen lohn mit langen arbeitszeiten
als animateur in einem ferienclub leute
zu unterhalten
bei ihm hat die resozialisierung
offenbar funktioniert das passiert nicht
mehr eine solche situation soll also
nicht mehr geben die überfall mit meiner
mutter sorgen weil sie sie hätte das
nicht verdient so traurig zu sein und
das hat auch sie seine leben geändert
nach diesem eine verhaftung es ist nicht
mehr wie einmal so wie ich auch
viele serben arbeiten in der schweiz und
bauen hier in den ferien mit dem sauer
verdienten geld große häuser für ihre
kinder wieder nie zurückkommen nur zoran
musste zurück in seine ursprüngliche
heimat in die schweiz durfte er nicht
nachdem er seine junge familie in
spanien verlassen hatte wenn er heute an
den postraub denkt kommt ihm immer das
gleiche in den sinn und seine von seinem
großvater so sagt er habe er dieses
gebäude geerbt zusammen mit einem
angestellten betreibt er hier eine
kleine holzkiste fabrik
[Musik]
alles macht einen etwas improvisierten
eindruck er hat mühleholz zu
organisieren für die kisten fabrikation
und wenn er die maschine an wirft es
geht häufig das licht aus
[Musik]
turan hat auch eine neue frau und mit
ihr ein kind immer wenn er heimweh nach
der schweiz hat kocht erwischte das sei
oft sagt er
[Musik]
seine neue frau weiß über den postraub
bescheid geld wie wir das machen nicht
mit
ja nicht mehr mit postbank ab nein da
darf das nicht mehr sicher nicht so groß
erlaubt ob vielleicht eine kleine bis
fünf millionen chefs
kein scherz weil er nämlich noch immer
nach seinen beuteanteil aus dem postraub
sucht und sich so immer wieder in
zwielichtige kreise begibt
wie das alte beziehungsnetz und wenn wir
wieder und griechen ort sich rufe auto
die gleichen freundeskreis abfragt und
dtb zum beispiel drogen oder auch die
vermögensdelikte oder sushi verkehr
auftaucht und eigentlich gang und gäbe
sind dann hat man das erhöhte risiko
rückfällig zu werden
das ist eine wichtige maßnahme probiert
im strafvollzug zu erwirken dass die
täter das neues bezirks netzaufbau dass
sich und so eine art illegalität
investieren damit sie wieder die alte
schema zugfahrt einer der in die
legalität investiert und trotzdem seien
kleinganoven image pflegt ist domenico
es vom fahrer ist er quasi zum
schriftsteller aufgestiegen und hat die
postraub geschichte aufschreiben lassen
das buch war 2009 gar ein bestseller
das ist spannend emotionen sind da schon
in tv- und wen wundert's er hat
natürlich keine ahnung vom verbleib des
geldes im buch schreibt er dass ein
gewisser luigi sich mit seinen
beuteanteil von vier millionen aus dem
staub gemacht habe und er ganz ehrlich
gar nichts mehr davon wissen
seine liebe mühe mit der legalität hat
hingegen maurizio v er braucht auch im
mai 2012 wieder mal seinen anwalt so
sehr er sich auch bessern wollte er hat
in seinem lokal mit kokain gehandelt und
ließ sich von einem verdeckten ermittler
der polizei erwischen
maurizio fausers 2011 des weg mehr als
drei monate in untersuchungshaft
aber wäre er nicht ein ehemaliger
posträuber würden sich die medien wohl
kaum für die aktuelle straftat
interessieren
der flug vom postraub hätten quasi colt
große ermittlungen
es ist ein v-mann gesetzt wurde was
übrig ist dass statt das geschieht vor
gericht also mehr behauptet nicht dass
der pharma unkorrekt sie ist aber jeder
frau marisa cent haltet die problematik
eines werke vom staat wäre das delikt
nicht stand
ich bin unschuldig
jene machen sind job und ich bin
trägheit und staunend zu
das hat das ganze jahr jetzt sind alle
sicher dass sie sicher nicht mehr von
vorstrafen also da wäre noch wirklich
aus auf ein idiot dass es auch weniger
zu wiegen keine stimme zu landen das
idiotisch
das bundesamt für statistik hat man
interessante untersuche gemacht so moser
finde wie viel verglüht wo im gefängnis
sie sind nachher wieder rückfällig
werden doch kann man sagen so rund ein
viertel wird nach zwei jahren rückfällig
und das stieg dann bis zu 50 prozent auf
jetzt interessant ist wenn man
ruhrgebiet diebstahl und beraubt und
frommer wenn das in kombination mit
betäubungsmittel delikt stadt dann ist
die rückfallrate bei 50 und mp3
kombination bis 70 prozent dass eine
sehr hohe rückfallquote werte
festgestellt
mauritius v passt voll in die statistik
aber obwohl er ein wiederholungstäter
ist bekommt der ehemalige posträuber die
24 monate bedingt dies weil das gericht
anerkennt dass der einsatz des
verdeckten ermittlers in seinem fall
wohl etwas übertrieben war
[Musik]
ich bin nie kriegen wir schon vorher
kräutern und ratsam wäre wohl in zukunft
wirklich in seiner pizzeria zu
investieren als in krumme geschäfte
[Musik]
domenico es ist 2012 wieder in sachen
postraub unterwegs im moment sei er
arbeitslos schreibe aber an seinem
zweiten buch
diesmal soll es ein roman werden thema
ist wer hätte es gedacht dem postraub
[Musik]
wie und wo genau detailliert was was
gewollt haben was nicht gehört haben was
wirklich euro verloren gegangen ist sind
die letzte wirklich zufrieden sind
ich will denn es hatte machen eine
erfundene geschichte soll es diesmal
werden die sache mit luigi der mit dem
geld abgehauen sei erschien nicht nur
uns im ersten buch schon sehr funktional
luigi ja also ich bin schon skull tisch
mit ihm ließen sie was bin ich froh bin
ich über freiheit hätte ich das geld
innerlich innerlich ob jemand will mir
glauben
und darum sage ich unsere besten wenn
jemand sagt ja warum zu einem
schriftsteller gehört auch ein agent
sagt er sich ein alter freund übernimmt
die rolle für ihn bezahlen werde er ihn
allerdings erst können wenn auch das
zweite buch ein erfolg wird
trotz neuer karriere
die schatten des post raubes wird auch
domenico es offenbar nicht richtig los
also postalischer vermittlung wurde sie
nach meiner entlassung habe ich immer
noch keine ruhe
zb letzten jahre wurde verhaftet ein
monat von irgend eine alte geschichte
von 2010 aber ein gericht in moskau hat
geistert eine vorbereitung des glaubens
also wenn das
stimmt wäre ich denke ich immer noch in
haft
aus der u-haft entlassen heißt noch
nicht freigesprochen
der prozess und das urteil stehe noch
aus domenico es hat sich für die fiktion
entschieden
schauspielerisches talent zumindest hat
er zweifellos wie weit er von seiner
beute doch profitiert hat diese wahrheit
erfährt man so natürlich nicht ganz
wer was von damals mit einer frühstück
frische partner politik banknoten sind
gewaltig die flügel jährige und die
hitze nicht so schnell aus aber
natürlich nicht sagen weil ein knoten
aus das center sind nummeriert aber
internet service also das waren die
bremsen sind noch gültig
bozen im mai 2012 volksfest der gebirgs
grenadiere an einem kleinen stand finden
wir einen alten bekannten
der ehemalige postangestellte mario p i
ist derjenige welcher nach der
entlassung aus dem gefängnis zu seinen
eltern zurück gekehrt war
15 jahre nach dem postraub ist er kaum
wiederzuerkennen
[Musik]
in italien weiß niemand um seine
vergangenheit
in italien bin ich nicht vorbestraft
absolut rein
ich war auch in der schweiz wegen dieser
fall
er hat eine feste stelle in einem
haushaltswarengeschäft ist vorgesetzter
von zwei angestellten und wohnt seit
jahren mit seiner freundin zusammen
ich bin mehr kriminell gewesen so wie
ich gesagt aber das ist nicht in meinen
genen also meine
der dnr und habe ich hier genug bezahlt
so glaube ich auch mehr als normal
sollte ich habe versucht mich so job zu
finden denn eine arbeit und ganz normale
leben dazu gehöre auch dass er jeden
kontakt mit den anderen post räubern
vermeiden eigentlich wollte er auch
überhaupt nicht mehr in den medien
auftreten
schließlich habe er längst mit diesem
kapitel aus seiner vergangenheit
abgeschlossen
erstes mal und jetzt habe ich ihm gesagt
und deswegen
ich denke die große unterschiede was sie
haben die gleichen fehler gemacht auch
wenn ich ja wir alle nicht
ich habe einfach für mich geschaut dass
ich genau die gleiche fälle nicht auch
wenn er sozusagen eine ausnahme
darstellt im reigen der ehemaligen
posträuber muss auch er sich immer
wieder die gleiche frage gefallen lassen
wir haben die ja meistens immer gefragt
werden das heißt schon nach 15 jahren er
wurde dass gelder sind und heute ist
muss man nicht mehr mit frage muss man
an die mandate fragen weil ich habe gar
keine halbe welt muss handwerken das
weiß ich nicht
[Musik]
einfach ist es nicht es bleibt immer die
erinnerung es bleibt immer die die
vergangenheit
sie bleibt mit dein leben auch wenn du
versucht zu vergessen aber kannst du
dich verbessern und das bin ich selber
glücklich gibt
die tat hat mario p kein glück gebracht
aber er scheint für sich einen weg in
die legalität gefunden zu haben
[Musik]
der jahrhundert postraub hat sein leben
verändert auch den fahndern bleibt der
außergewöhnliche fall bis heute in
erinnerung
also ich habe sehr gern gemacht
ich habe nie hat nun also das macht mir
sehr gerne aber wenn mein größter wenn
er hinter haben wir schon mal zurück nur
gibt dann ist man auch sehr froh wenn
svp ist und dachte stolz hatte ich muss
ich mir das vorstellen ja wenn es ein
erfolg wenn man im krieg zu führen
mit der gerechten strafe zuführen und
große teile futter blüht die führte
geschädigt die zu kohle dann in der
folge musste scholz nun verhält was
macht das mit ihnen ja das ist ein
wermutstropfen das ist schade dass ich
vor allem schade für die trickdiebe
stich wird hoffe dass das irgendwann als
führer und dabei sind wir doch
realistisch noch 15 jahre sind chance
kriegen das leuchtet allen ein nur einem
nicht zu rantzau treffen die in belgrad
im mai 2012 ist er gerade wieder einmal
aus dem gefängnis entlassen worden
in zürich bedrohte er einen mann mit
einem heißen bügeleisen und geld von ihm
zu erpressen
dafür hat er als wiederholungstäter zwei
jahre gefängnis bekommen
[Musik]
auf seinem konto habe er noch 30 euro
seine kleine fabrik steht still seine
zweite frau hat ihn mit der kleine
tochter verlassen
er scheint zwar vom leben gezeichnet
aber ob er je erwachsen wird uns kommt
es nicht so vor
da besser gefallen
warum
august
bei den arbeitsreichen post
so
ja sagt die jedem
und das macht man nicht am besten sollte
man selbst
die anzeige der stadt wieder wir können
das jetzt nicht zum beispiel in spanien
reagieren das geld hat man die spanische
der schweizerischen anzeige nach zehn
jahre geldwäsche geldwäsche reist schon
also vorbei also es kommt nichts mehr
druck machen zeigt über den kommunen
zeige ich auch legale wege kann ich das
geld wert
darum hat er auch so gemacht verletzte
macht und er hat mir angezeigt habe ich
vergessen zweite stadt weiterstadt
schweizer stadt klagt wie ich immer noch
an also dass sich hin und sein millionen
700000 franken schulter dann kannst du
dir vorstellen wie viel habe ich im
abgegeben und der personen ab der person
die person lebt jetzt gut hat seine
tochter schloss schule gemacht hat
mehrere immobilien und ich muss hier der
arbeit suchen und arbeiten
ich glaube ich habe ihm traut
dass er das geld selbst auch gestohlen
hat dieses unrechtsbewusstsein scheint
ihm völlig abzugehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unseren hirsch nach ungarn zurück
was immer
eigentlich nicht
das stolz von einem macht das nicht
möglich
[Musik]
ob die strafe in seinem fall etwas
genützt hat fragt man sich bei zoran v
zurecht
die suche nach seinem beuteanteil hielt
ihm bisher immer wieder davon ab eine
legale arbeit zu suchen
[Musik]
die strafe im gefängnis abgeguckt hat
hat schon etwas gebracht aber wohl du in
der schweiz in hier gekommen bist in
serbien und keine andere eine andere
welt heißt da nimmst du immer das
gleiche motto am meisten kennst
[Musik]
ob das der richtige weg ist er wollte
sich nicht unterkriegen lassen sagt er
und hat sich wieder etwas ausgedacht
voran vw wein von serbien nach afrika
exportieren
ob das eine gute idee ist und zudem gibt
es halt auch solche die werden einfach
immer erwischt
halbzeit
ich bin 40 minuten statt event riesa zum
so hat der dollar
jetzt besucht er erst einmal einen der
wenigen freunde die er noch habe in
serbien der hat eine angelausrüstung
irgendwie so scheint es ist so ralf
immer wieder auf der suche nach dem
großen fang
[Musik]
und das ist die perspektive in serbien
ja die perspektive ist es gibt
eigentlich keine richtige perspektive
aber muss man aufbauen
langsam also ich meine ich probiere es
ist schwierig nach dem wieder nachdem im
gefängnis etwas aufzubauen die leute
schauen dich mit anderen augen und ist
alles wieder von anfang an aber man muss
nicht aufgeben muss kämpfen und auf
legale weise stein auf stein und drückt
und was bleibt ihr zurück von post trat
das
der frau münster postraub geblieben ist
den tätern wenig bis nichts
profitiert haben höchstens dritte
diejenigen die das geld versteckt oder
gewaschen haben
wer das sein könnte und ob sie damit
glücklich sind
[Musik]
ja